[Music]
so today we cancel forest bennett who's
a democratic lawmaker in oklahoma who
had uh had what he thought was a
brilliant idea last week he tweeted out
triumphantly
this week i filed hb 3129 which codifies
that a father's financial responsibility
to his baby and their mother begins at
conception if oklahoma is going to
restrict a woman's right to choose we
sure better make sure that the men
involved can't just walk away from their
responsibilities now this was meant to
be a dunk on the evil pro-lifers who
forrest believed only opposed abortion
because of their deep hatred for women
he believed this despite the fact that
the pro-life movement is led primarily
by women just go watch the march for
life watch the footage
what about those women well they must
all be self-hating misanthropes he
decided because to the left
the self-hating women are the ones who
oppose abortion you know not the ones
who say cut their breasts off and try to
become men no they're not they're not
self-hating it's it's it's the women who
don't want to kill babies they're the
self-hating ones
in any case forrest attempted dunk
unfortunately for him hit the back of
the rim bounced back out
while forrest fell to the court broke
his arm and the whole stadium pointed
and laughed
he thought
that the right would shake their fists
violently and say you know damn you
forest you foiled our patriarchal plot
but instead conservatives all supported
the bill
everyone on the right on social media
they're all saying this is great i love
it thank you
after all our position is that babies
are human beings with rights
and that parents should be required to
care for their children or else find
someone who will care for them you owe
that to your child
your child is entitled to be cared for
we have a lot of entitlements in our
culture today we hear a lot about what
people are entitled to
well here's one example of an actual
entitlement
your child
is entitled to be taken care of you have
that responsibility to your child and
again if you can't fulfill that
responsibility or don't want to then you
find someone who will
what you cannot do is abandon them
or certainly kill them outright
that's our position if you feel like you
are getting the respect you deserve in
life well i've got a solution for you
establish titles is your opportunity to
earn the title of lord or lady and gain
the respect you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
scotland in your title pack you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and the best
way to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends or boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles is having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com walsh or just click the link
below now of course of course we think
that this principle should apply to men
as well
in fact a bill that codifies a father's
financial responsibility to his baby in
the womb
also codifies that the baby in the womb
is in fact a baby
he's a person a legal entity who has
owed certain basic legal protections
why wouldn't we support that
forrest could only look around in horror
as the people he was trying to anger
with his bill instead cheered him on
while the people he was trying to
impress instead were angry
so a day later he tweeted this follow-up
he said
well this has been fun i appreciate
those who understood the message behind
this bill and those who provided sincere
constructive feedback and pointed out
serious issues with practical
application also a great way to be
reminded that 280 characters isn't
enough for some discussions
i'm muting this now because i've read
most if not all of the comments and i
hear those who came here to help me
understand angles to this that i hadn't
considered i also hear those who came
here just to be mean or condescending
and hey it's twitter what was i
expecting
let me get this out of the way by the
way the mean people were all just the
ones who said it's a good bill and they
like it
but that's mean because it's the people
that it's the wrong people he didn't
want those people to to be supported
he continues let me get this out of the
way obviously i'm not moving forward
with this bill as written i'm glad many
of you understood the idea but it
clearly needs work so to actual
constituents of mine who requested that
i go back to the drawing board i hear
you
now what can we learn from this aside
from the fact that forest bennett is a
stupid pathetic little embarrassing
goober who wrote a bill just to troll
his opponents but instead uh trolled his
own side by accident
i think the really there really is the
most important lesson is this
um aside from from the fact that he's
stupid and embarrassed
the second maybe is the fact that the
pro-abortion side
and the left broadly speaking
has so
thoroughly insulated itself so
completely hidden itself in its own
cocoon
that the people on that side have come
to actually believe the straw men that
they've constructed
they're buying into their own hype
it's hard to fathom this as someone who
lives in reality
but many pro boards do really think that
the anti-abortion side is motivated by
nothing but animosity for women
now it's not that they've been fooled
into thinking this by some outside force
they fooled themselves
forrest bennett
thought that pro-lifers would have a
problem with requiring men to care for
their children even though we're the
ones who are always talking about the
problem of fatherless homes
we're the ones always calling for men to
take responsibility
our whole point again is that babies are
people and their parents have a duty to
care for them
so
how could the other side
come to actually believe that the
pro-life position is all just a smoke
screen and our real intention is to
enslave women
well partly it's stupidity and
intellectual laziness but also it's a
kind of emotional self-preservation i
think
their own position
is so morally hideous
and they are so clearly and deeply in
the wrong
that they wouldn't be able to face
themselves or sleep at night if they
allowed themselves to engage honestly
with the opposing viewpoint
their only choice is to make a cartoon
out of us
they have to retreat into fantasy
otherwise they would notice the blood
stains on their hands
and the mountain of dead bodies that
they're standing on
they can't handle that confrontation
with reality until reality forces itself
to be seen and to be known
as happened to poor forest bennett who
is today of course for that reason
finally canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated